mais d'abord le portrait du nouveau
brunswick en fleurs avec samia de sheer
c'est la fin d'un règne de 16 ans
aujourd'hui la chancelière allemande
angela merkel a confié les clés du pays
à son successeur olaf scholz celui qui
fut à plusieurs reprises ministre du
travail puis des finances dans gala
merkel revendique une certaine forme de
continuité avec elle je suis très
reconnaissant de ce que nous avons fait
jusqu'à présent je me réjouis de cette
nouvelle tâche je me réjouis de tout ce
travail ce sera un nouveau départ pour
notre pays un nouveau départ car olaf
scholz n'est pas du même bord qu'angela
merkel elle est conservatrice lui est un
social démocrate
successivement député ministre maire de
hambourg cet avocat de 63 ans a vite
grimpé les échelons du spd son élection
fait basculer l'allemagne à gauche une
gauche plutôt centriste car sur le plan
économique olaf scholz est plutôt
libérale et surtout sa majorité repose
sur une coalition inédite formée entre
les sociaux démocrates les verts et le
parti libéral son gouvernement aux
couleurs de ses trois parties a été reçu
ce matin par le président de la
république allemande
je vous félicite pour la conclusion
rapide et réussie de vos négociations de
coalition et je vous félicite tous
chaleureusement une fois encore pour
votre nomination aujourd'hui vous porter
désormais la responsabilité de notre
pays et de plus de 82 millions de
personnes vous avez défendu cette
responsabilité lors des élections et
vous faites face à cette responsabilité
en ces temps difficiles
la nouvelle coalition au pouvoir s'est
entendu sur un programme de compromis
entre mesures sociales et rigueur
budgétaire
également axé sur le climat et l'union
européenne
et c'est à la france partenaires
européens historiques du pays colette
scholz a réservé son premier déplacement
il sera reçu vendredi à l'elysée par
emmanuel macron
et cette visite ce sera évidemment l'un
des thèmes de notre des bajoues présente
mais inviter nos invités is a good un
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes maîtresse de
conférences en histoire et civilisation
allemande contemporaine à paris iii
sorbonne nouvelle christian makarian
bonsoir journalise ans élise des
relations internationales patrick martin
grenier bonsoir bienvenue aussi
spécialisé questions européennes
enseignera à sciences po vous publiez
l'europe at elle un avenir c'est aux
éditions studyrama avec non duplex
fabienne keller fabienne keller députés
centristes au parlement européen bonjour
bonsoir ancienne maire de strasbourg
évidemment bienvenue à vous aussi et
puis à mes côtés matthieu croissandeau
éditorialiste politique bonsoir monsieur
bonsoir tout vous retourner évidemment
comme tous les lundis et mercredis
l'apprenti mutti on a on a piqué ce
titre à nos confrères de libération pour
lancer ce débat et je commence justement
par sa personnalité la personnalité du
nouveau chancelier allemand est ce que
vous diriez qu'il a des points communs
avec angela merkel et lisa goudin oui il
a beaucoup de points communs avec avec
angela merkel on les qualifie souvent
tous deux de pragmatique donc qui savent
s'adapter à des situations et une autre
lecture serait de dire que c'est une
forme d'un consistance ou même
d'opportunisme politique mais en tout
cas c'est des gens qui s'adapte assez
facilement qu'ils sont pas fixés sur une
idéologie et qui sont assez tenace tous
les deux il a subi pas mal de revers en
tant que maire de hambourg au moment où
la population avait refusé les jo pour
sa vie par exemple contient les
débordements du g20 ou quand il a tenté
de se faire élire à la présidence du spd
qu'il a été dépassé par deux inconnus a
donc il a connu des revers et ça l'a
jamais empêché de
poursuivre son ascension donc ça c'est
aussi quelque chose cette tenacité je
pense que c'est aussi un point commun
est ce que vous diriez qu'il est
charismatique christian makarian n'ont
pas c'est une première des kivu
est-ce que angela merkel était à
proprement parler charismatique ni elle
a forgé un charisme à partir de son
absence de charisme son intégrité sa
morale ça constituer sa probité sa
modestie zoo son humilité même au niveau
2 nuls du style de vie et du train d'hui
fêter son arrivée à bangui en défilant
au louvre avec avec la pyramide de
jeunes je ne suis je ne suis pas sûr que
affectionner ce genre de manifestation
oui et ça forge est un personnage un
tout de même donc il faut pas présumer
trop de l'absence de charisme de
monsieur scholtes l'allemagne et une
puissance et un elle-même le système
institutionnel politique allemand
fabrique regardez cette incroyable
coalition mais on y revient sur le
système était incroyablement solide il
travaille avant c'est exactement
l'inversé de la france alors qu'en
france on est happé par le pouvoir
deux cents à l'heure qui est entre les
mains principalement d'un seul homme
peut-être un jour d'une femme mais enfin
tout cas une seule personne et ensuite
on réfléchit aux erreurs qu'on a
commises là c'est l'inversé on a tous le
ton de la brume je vous interromps parce
que l'on va on va ouvrir évidemment un
chapitre que l'on jouait très négatif
j'ai bien entendu patrick martin grenier
ils sont ils sont pas de la même famille
politique avec angela merkel mais est-ce
qu'ils sont par leur là je parle pas de
la personnalité mais peut-être sur les
idées est ce qu'ils sont
fondamentalement différents non cela
vient d'être dit il sont similaires et
d'ailleurs rappelez vous que la choisit
je serai la future merkel future
chancelière donc il a limité ses gestes
génération voilà cette attitude qui
était si c'est vraiment typique d'un
gala merkel parce que effectivement
c'est quelqu'un qui a une grande
expérience qui a le nez dans le guidon
si vous me passez l'expression c'est
quelqu'un qui est toujours présent
ministre des finances qui a su comme on
dit ouvrir les caisses de l'état
notamment lors de cette pandémie
également faut pas l'oublier lors du
drame qu'a vécu l'allemagne au moment
des inondations de cet été alors que ses
deux principaux concurrents faisait des
gaffes notamment armin l'achète en se
riant devant les victoires riant devant
les victimes là effectivement il a été
présent c'est un homme qui rassure c'est
un homme qui a beaucoup travaillé
presque dans l'ombre il n'a pas de
charisme avec angela merkel la
chancelière et on disait effectivement
qu'en france tout dépend d'un seul homme
c'est le système institutionnel en
allemagne rien ne se fait sans
concertation et ce contrat qui a été
signé 277 pages je crois c'est vraiment
la feuille de route qui va guider ce
gouvernement indépendamment des ego des
personnalités pendant les quatre ans qui
viennent donc c'est important il ne
prendra aucune décision sans qu'il ait
une concertation au sein de la coalition
dont finalement ce manque de charisme
n'est pas un handicap au contraire c'est
quelque chose qui va permettre à ce
gouvernement de fonctionner correctement
oui on va peut-être pas beaucoup rigolé
avec la chose mais en même temps c'est
pas ce qu'on demande à un chef de
gouvernement
fabienne keller est ce qu'il est
francophile francophone comment vous
percevez l'arrivée de cet homme au
pouvoir oh oui il est très proche de la
france il a d'ailleurs annoncé que sa
première visite serait pour la france il
a rencontré le président emmanuel macron
donc il est très fidèle et c'est bien
retracée dans l'accord de coalition à
cet axe franco allemand qui est
important en terme de force de
propositions pour l'europe c'est un
homme expérimenté on l'a dit maintenant
pour il vient de il sort d'un mandat de
ministre des finances
il connaît bien aussi le parlement
allemand et c'est très important dans
leur système qui selon le chancelier
doit sans cesse être soutenu dans ses
orientations par le parlement c'est un
système qui est très appuyé sur un quasi
système parlementaire donc il est innée
bien formés pour être prêt à diriger
dans les règles allemandes le pays en
lien avec avec ses partenaires européens
donc une une personnalité très très
solide très robuste
s'habituer aussi aux coups durs comme
cela
la résilience d'une personnalité
politique
on va venir vous l'avez dit le premier
rendez vous alors c'est la tradition
dans ce qu'on appelle encore le couple
franco allemand la première visite est
réservé soit à paris soit berlin
emmanuel macron lui a donné rendez vous
sur sur twitter dans les deux langues la
suite nous l'écrirons ensemble écrit le
prix en français pour les français pour
les allemands pour les européens à
vendredi
mathieu l'arrivée de ce nouveau
chancelier est ce que ça change quand
même un peu la donne pour justement le
couple franco-allemand et ça change
forcément un peu la donne d'abord en
raison de la personnalité ou plutôt du
statut particulier qui avait enlevé la
merkel sur la scène européenne et même
dans la relation entre entre paris et
berlin vous rappeler qu'elle a connu
quatre présidents français l'avait
vraiment un statut à part ça ça lui
confère une place je disais à part dans
le paysage est ce que olaf scholz qui
exerce la même fonction aura tout de
suite immédiatement la même aura la même
confiance la même influence
pas tout de suite sans doute ensuite
cette annonce et cette arrivée du
nouveau chancelier pardon elle arrive à
un moment où l'union européenne est un
moment clé de son existence même elle se
remet à peine du récit tel est contestée
sur le plan politico institutionnelle
comme l'a rarement été par des états
membres elle doit affronter des crises
conjoncturelles qui ne sont pas
terminées l'aco vide la crise migratoire
et elle doit résoudre des défis
structurels qu'il y en a qui qui qui qui
sont très important pour son avenir la
transition écologique son modèle
économique
son poids géopolitique aussi pour n'en
citer que quelques-uns et puis enfin la
troisième raison pour laquelle ça risque
de changer un petit peu la donne quoi
qu'on en dise même si c'est il est
allemand avant d'être social démocrate
il est quand même sociale-démocrate
s'est il a pas la même couleur politique
et il est à la tête d'une collection qui
a de solides ambitions réformatrices
pour l'europe et puis il prend ses
marques à un moment où la france
d'occuper la présidence de l'union
européenne et à un moment où la france
s'apprête elle-même à vivre une grande
élection de quoi black tous ces éléments
là peuvent quand même bousculé un petit
peu un petit peu la donne ça fait une
équation à plusieurs inconnues qui filme
en attendant alors d'abord la relation
franco-allemande de jeu par le contrôle
de tous nos experts il peut-être qui me
contrediront n'est pas en mauvais état
aujourd'hui mais les oeillades et les
embrassades auquel on a eu droit
des adieux dans le gard à mr khaled
emmanuel macron ne doivent pas non plus
effacer quelques quiproquos quelques-uns
désaccord quelques incompréhensions vous
souvenez du grand discours d' emmanuel
macron sur l'avenir de l'europe au début
de son quinquennat qui n'avait pas été
suivie de beaucoup d'effets de de
l'autre côté du rhin de ce point de vue
d'ailleurs le président français devrait
peut-être trouvé une oreille un peu plus
attentive dans la coalition que mène à
olaf scholz sur les questions
économiques par exemple la corde
collection prévoit y compris de
renégocier des traités budgétaire alors
que les allemands restent évidemment
très attaché à la réduction de la dette
mais il n'écarte pas cette possibilité
et est depuis de ce point de vue je le
plan de relance européen tel qu'il a été
voté était un premier pas important
deuxième chose c'est que cette nouvelle
coalition avaient même désormais plus
loin que les rêves des manèges macron en
termes d'intégration européenne
puisqu'elle défend vraiment une europe
fédérale et on sait que la france y est
réticente et puis va y avoir quelques
quelques points de discussion et
peut-être de désaccord la question du
nucléaire bien sûr et puis sur le plan
géopolitique y compris même sur le plan
du commerce international ou la
diplomatie est ce que l'allemagne sera -
atlantis qu'elle ne l'a été ce qu'elle
sera plus sourcilleuses en négociant des
grands accords commerciaux est ce que ce
sera plus ferme où on arrive qu'elle ne
l'a été avec pékin et comment réagira la
france est ce qu'ils seront sur la même
ligne tout ça fait évidemment question
et puis on attend des réponses qui
dépendront aussi du prochain président
ou présidente français il ya un premier
élément de réponse pour les relations
internationales au losc a déjà tapé du
poing sur la table vis-à-vis de la
russie il a menacé de possibles
conséquences sur le gazoduc north stream
ii en cas d'invasion de l'ukraine par
les troupes russes est-ce qu'il peut
marquer son territoire christian bach a
rien sur ce point sensible pour la
souveraineté allemande alors encore une
fois il est tenu par la coalition dans
l'abolition il ya des écologistes des
verts qui sont très très crispée sur la
question des droits de l'homme donc ça
vise directement la chine et la russie
donc
il ya cet élément là
ensuite monsieur scholz s'est signalé
par un certain nombre d'idées parfois un
peu surprenante notamment au détriment
de la france vont se souvenir qu'en 2018
il a proposé unilatéralement tout seul
comme un grand que le siège
de membre permanent au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu qu'occupe la france
soit partagée entre à l'époque 28 pays
puisque l'angleterre enfin le royaume
uni en faisait encore partie et ça a été
très très peu apprécié à paris sur tout
cela n'a pas été extrêmement concertée
comme opposition au monsieur shot altéré
a tracé une ligne plus droite et a
démontré une plus grande maîtrise des
relations internationales je pense quand
même que le sujet de la russie va être
crucial parce que mois de mars à peu
près prochain l'autre stream 2 sera
officiellement inaugurée que sur saône
au stream ii il ya une pression
américaine très fat joe biden utilise la
menace de suspension de ce no stream 2
contre la russie mais de l'autre côté
pour ménager l'allemagne il a consenti à
ce que l'allemagne qui a besoin du gaz
russe poursuivent et achève ce grand
projet donc c'est un jour compliqué dans
lequel se trouve olaf scholz le plus
intéressant pour lui c'est d'avoir un
grand projet avec la france un grand
projet international
déjà concernant l'europe un partenariat
stratégique
ça a été précisée dans le contrat de
coalition le document auquel monsieur
martin genêt faisait allusion tout à
l'heure qu'il est 177 pages qui
prévoient tous les cas de figure
et c'est quelque chose qu'on peut pas
imaginer quand on est français c'est
plus de deux mois de négociations oui
mais tout est prévu si le ministre de
l'intérieur démissionne qui le remplace
si une femme s'en va comment on la
remplace si tous les cas de figure sont
prévues y compris la désignation de
l'adversaire de la démocratie allemande
qui est nommément précisé dans le
contrat et qui est l'extrême droite
c'est intéressant c'est ça qui est
définie c'est le point commun entre les
verts les libéraux est parce qu elles
libéreront très peur et sa droite bien
sûr ils sont assez proches de l'esa pas
de l'extrême droite mais dans la droite
quand même de la droite donc pour eux
c'est vital et puis bien sûr le spd mais
sur le cas des avocats patrick martin
geniez la la la feuille de route du
gouvernement de dollars elle est
européenne très européenne oui ça vient
d'être dit vous l'avez souligné
effectivement il ya du poids du corps
c'est à dire que lille sont
effectivement pour une europe fédérale
quand on est pour une europe fédérale ce
sont les verts qui ont poussé pour cela
c'est une europe à d'intégrer
politiquement c'est à dire on est
presque pour les états unis d'europe
alors qu'on voit bien que du côté de la
france va finalement on a toujours été
favorable à une rupture
intergouvernementale on le voit bien
aujourd'hui le pouvoir est en train
d'être transférés aux chefs d'état et de
gouvernement la commission a vu son rôle
diminuer alors que c'est la commission
est l'instance fédérale devient un
aspect europe est très important mais
aussi sur le plan économique cela vient
d'être souligné même sur des traits
européen sur le plan économique vous
l'avez souligné sur ce point
effectivement le ministre des finances
qui est le chef du fdp monsieur lee
denner est partisan d'une orthodoxie
budgétaire très strictes et ça sur ce
point ils pourraient avoir des frictions
avec paris notamment sur la
mutualisation de la dette sur les
déficits publics mais incontestablement
cette européen ceci dit on vient de
parler de la russie de la chine de
nordstream faut pas oublier que dans le
contrat de gouvernement aussi on a
obligé les verts a signé une totale
solidarité avec l'otan et donc par
conséquent l'allemagne reste l'allemagne
c'est à dire finalement et seront
d'abord solidaire de l'otan et
et est partisan également d'une relation
plus tôt on va dire apaisée avec la
russie parce que l'allemagne n'a pas les
moyens de partir dans un conflit avec la
russie même si les verts veulent mettre
l'accent sur la protection des droits de
l'homme alors c'est intéressant quand
vous parlez de l'europe fédérale parce
qu'il ya un sondage au doxa pour le
figaro qui vient de de sortir là c'était
il ya un quart d'heure qui questionne
les français sur la présidence française
de l'union à partir du 1er janvier et
justement cette idée cette proposition
d'une europe fédérale elle est soutenue
par 58 % des personnes interrogées moi
ce qui m'étonne un petit peu fabienne
keller je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
mais si on rentrer un peu dans le détail
de ce qui est l'europe fédérale je ne
suis pas sûr que ce chiffre resterait
aussi élevé et vous
je pense que très logiquement les
français tirent les enseignements de ce
qu'on vient de vivre pour la crise c'est
une europe qui s'efface en sang de
manière solidaire un événement subi qui
a été plus forte c'est l'europe qui a
permis qu'on soit tous alimentés en
vaccins on a vu d'ailleurs combien les
réflexes européens sont apparus on se
compare on cherche les bonnes pratiques
les uns chez les autres et puis ce plan
de relance
l'allemagne qui acceptent une des deux
communes c'est un fait historique
de manière à ce que le rebond économique
soit plus rapide que ce qu'on a connue
après la crise de 2008 donc c'est ce
fédéralisme là que je voudrais lire dans
la proposition qui est soutenu par les
français comme comme les allemands les
allemands proposent qu'on investisse
plus massivement ensemble dans le
ferroviaire dans les investissements
énergétiques dans les infrastructures
c'est une robe très au service des
concitoyens dans ce sens et les
fédérales au sens où on a conscience
qu'on a un destin partagé on est très
proche économiquement on est très
proches socialement il faut aussi que
nos normes sociales petit à petit ce
généraliste les bonnes pratiques soient
soient copiés soit généralisée et à cet
égard moi je me réjouis vraiment j'ai
cette amitié franco-allemande qui semble
être une tradition mais c'est aussi une
salle et moi j'aime bien rappeler qu'on
est très différent entre français et
allemands à strasbourg je le vis bien
donc c'est pour ça que quand les
français et les allemands arrivent à
trouver une base de travail en commun et
ben c'est une bonne base pour être
élargi aux 27 états membres donc
franchement c'est le plein d'espoir ce
l'arrivée
très tranquille et elisa goudin c'est
une tradition mais c'est une
construction aussi ça veut dire que
c'est un travail des différents chefs
d'état ou de gouvernement depuis depuis
deux décennies la la la la solidité on
va dire de ceux de ce moteur franco
allemand oui oui sans le moteur franco
allemand l'europe fonctionne pas à tout
le monde en est conscient et alors juste
c'est pas gagné d'avancé ça ça veut dire
quand la nuque c'est une construit le
couple fanfan dit pas couple en
allemagne d'ailleurs il ya la relation
franco allemande où l'amitié
franco-allemande le partenariat franco
allemand n'est jamais aussi forts qu'au
moment des crises très forte en fait
c'est à chaque fois ça que l'histoire
montre et allait regagner quand même une
petite limite peut-être
cette note d'espoir que je partage
globalement mais c'est que c'est cette
décision de l'allemagne de en effet
historique d'accepter le principe d'une
dette commune pour d'ailleurs olaf
scholz avait employé l'expression de
bazooka pour vraiment faire un grand
coup contre 20 pour aider l'économie à
sortir de là de la pandémie des
conséquences de la pandémie mais pour
christian lindner le chef des libéraux
ça doit être une seule fois il n'est pas
question que ça devienne pérenne et
alors que voilà on va beaucoup de
souhaiterait que ça devienne quelque
chose qui qu'il soit qui puisse être
pérenne sûrement avoir un retour à
l'orthodoxie budgétaire assez rapide à
verser annoncé joie dès 2023 je crois
c'est la date voilà voilà
parce que ça c'était la ligne rouge en
fait dans ce contrat de coalition chacun
des trois avaient posé des lignes rouges
et ils ont pu tous faire faire valoir sa
et faire des compromis sur votre chemin
et la ligne rouge pour les libéraux
s'étaient en retour à angers voilà
exactement c'est patrick martin louis
vous avez tout à fait raison mais il
faut pas oublier les objectifs de
politique intérieure car la chasse à un
objectif social très important ces
dernières années on a quand même vu la
multiplication des grèves en allemagne
on a quand même vu une dislocation de la
sorte de fracture sociale si vous voulez
avec des grèves des genres en précarité
et pas uniquement à l'est mais également
à l'ouest et ailleurs il annonce une
hausse due du salaire horaire sap avait
passé une fort aux 72 et une hausse
importante mais quand même quelque chose
d'important ça va impacter les finances
publiques assez considérablement il a
annoncé aussi je crois une assurance
pour les jeunes pour les étudiants des
choses en faveur des femmes seules des
mères de famille qui ont des difficultés
donc un agenda social très important et
je crois que cela va aussi impacter les
finances publiques mais ça a été inscrit
dans le programme de gouvernement
les libéraux sont d'accord mais ça comme
il l'a dit un jour il a dû je ne
donnerai pas plus d'argent qu'il y en a
ce qui veut dire que ce qu'on donne d'à
côté va falloir le restreinte de l'autre
côté donc c'est toujours ce principe de
l'orthodoxie budgétaire mais une
politique qui sera plus orienté
socialement mathieu il ya un certain
nombre de réformes qui sont annoncées
dans cette feuille de route là je
parlais de la hausse du salaire minimum
il ya la légalisation du cannabis y ait
le droit de vote à 16 ans il ya le
recours massif aux énergies
renouvelables est ce que ça peut peser
une façon d'une autre sur la sur la
campagne française ou sur le programme
du futur ou de la future présidente non
parce que les allant sur les allemands
et on s'en inspire on va leur en valeur
rendre visite anne delvaux rêverait
d'être la seule française comme toujours
comme cd socio-démocrate puisse la même
chose quand c'est des conservateurs mais
sur les questions sociétales ont cessé
ce ne sont pas les mêmes les mêmes
problématiques regarder sur la question
migratoire n'a pas du tout été géré
même façon en allemagne qu'en france le
sujet de l'immigration a très peu été
abordé de mémoire pendant la campagne sa
douce les dix y compris enfin pas par
les partis principaux et y compris
l'extrême mentale du mal à imposer cette
agence mais parce que je crois que
c'était quelque chose qui n'intéressait
plus les allemands les migrants se sont
là se sont très bien intégrés moment des
inondations dont vous parliez ils sont
venus par cars entiers et des et donc
les allemands c'est plus un sujet en
fait sa légende réussi là on aura
intégrationniste doivent regarder notre
campagne présidentielle de partir avec
un regard assez critique oui sur ces
thèmes identitaires comme comme inédit
chez nous alors il ya un point de
friction dont il faut parler entre la
france et l'allemagne jeune frisson il y
en a plusieurs mais en hameaux qui qui
m'intéresse c'est cesser la question du
nucléaire et du gaz et notamment du fis
des financements européens christian
makarian c'est ce qu'on appelle la
taxonomie européenne c'est à dire où est
ce que l'argent de l'europe va aller
pour la transition écologique là il ya
un bras de fer pour savoir si le
nucléaire peut être intégré à la liste
les allemands disent non ou si le gaz
peut être été intégré à la liste alors
madame
anna lena baer boc la ministre donc des
étrangers s'étaient candidate inverse la
voilà qui n'a aucune expérience des
affaires étrangères et qui n'est pas
spécialement deux diplomates n'ont plus
de tempérament donc ça fait de handicap
mais encore une fois le système
institutionnel allemand est tellement
solide que ce genre de nomination est
tout à fait possible et elle pourrait
nous surprendre madame herbach ne veut
pas du nucléaire et pour autant lcl
obtenu l'engagement que le charbon
reculerait donc on va vers les nouvelles
technologies
c'est ça la ligne du no go du
gouverement et schott et est très très
porté lui-même sur toutes ces nouvelles
technologies c'est un point un peu sur
lequel l'industrie allemande est un peu
en retard par rapport à son excellence
sur d'autres points donc il ya un
intérêt chaudes se représenta synthèse
entre l'intérêt industriel et l'intérêt
idéologique des verts s'ils voulaient la
toute l'allemagne peut se retrouver dans
un énorme effort vers les nouvelles
technologies
beaucoup moins polluante et les énergies
de substitution
là il ya un grand plan c'est là qu'on
pourrait imaginer quelque chose avec la
france de très constructif comme sur
l'intelligence artificielle
on pourrait imaginer un effort commun
franco-allemand tout à fait décisif mais
nous ne sommes pas en france sur ce
point de sur cette ligne-là nous tenons
nucléaire et même les échos les mêmes
c'est même un atout pour la crise
écologique augis français
n'envisage absolument pas de supprimer
le caire il va baisser son pourcentage
met en gardé tout de même une partie
substantielle voilà il ya une grande
différence
d'approché mais il y en a encore
beaucoup d'autres et une d'entre elles
bien sûr c'est on en a parlé
l'orthodoxie budgétaire
et là il y aura quand même une chose un
peu bizarre pour la france on va donc
avoir la présence d' union européenne
pendant 6 mois 1 mais au cinquième mois
de ses six mois on va peut-être changer
de président peut-être reconduire le
même clou mais peut-être en changer donc
il va y avoir une espèce de jeu de
chaises musicales assez bizarre
supposons que madame pécresse par
exemple unis ça tout à fait au hasard
c'est dans l'air du temps de la snel
succèdent c'est une pure hypothèse mais
succède à monsieur macro il va falloir
qu'elle marque son cap même s'ils
restent même en un mois elle a dit
qu'elle avait deux tiers de madame
merkel
sur cette question et comparé à hengelo
mais un autre élément du sondage eux aux
hawks apparu
ce soir
les français sont deux fois plus
nombreux à considérer je vous posais la
question là-dessus fabienne keller les
français sont deux fois plus nombreux à
considérer que l'union européenne sera
un atout plutôt qu'un handicap pour
emmanuel macron comment vous percevez
vous cette opportunité de la présidence
française ah c'est une grande chambre
évidemment c'est une grosse
responsabilité pour la france d'en
assurer la présidence mais c'est quelque
part dans l'échelle des manuels macro il
a une est profondément européen rappelez
vous son discours de la sorbonne qui à
l'époque n'avait pas entendu déco en
allemagne parce que l'allemagne elle
même était en difficulté politique mais
dès qu'il a pu malade merkel a tendu la
main ont repris la main tendue plus tôt
et a mis en oeuvre et c'est vrai que ce
couple a été extrêmement puissants
pendant la crise que nous venons de
vivre donc oui les convictions
européennes emmanuel macron pourront
pleinement trouvé leur force et leur
apprendre à bien besoin dans le cadre de
cette présidence donc pour ma part je
formule le voeu que le président m'a
qu'on puisse bien assurer les six mois
de présidence complète c'est-à-dire
avant l'élection présidentielle et après
c'est à dire que moi je suis dans la
majorité présidentielle je suis dans le
mouvement agir la droite constructif qui
fait partie de cette majorité et je dois
dire que les 26 autres états membres
attendent beaucoup de la france à 26
peut-être qu'on en peut en enlever deux
ou trois avec la hongrie la pologne mais
l'europe atteint cette présidence
française une présidence très européenne
attend qu'on fasse avancer les sujets
sociaux ça tombe bien avec avec les
allemands le sujet de la axone omis que
vous venez d'évoquer difficile qui
nécessitera bon compromis probablement
ou le gaz et le nucléaire seront
acceptés comme énergie transitoire pour
avancer dans ce green deal qui est
tellement important pour limiter le
réchauffement climatique mais où les
ressources les énergies renouvelables
peuvent pas instantanément d'un coup de
baguette magique rend pas c'est tout le
charbon un terreau une seconde parce que
en vous entendant dire que l'europe
attend beaucoup de la présidence
française de l'union elisa goût d'un jeu
vous voyez réagir est ce que l'allemagne
en attend beaucoup est ce qu'on n'est
pas un peu nous avec un voile à un
miroir un peu un effet loupe quoi oui
sur les attentes de cette présidence
française comment vous réagissez à ça
je trouve ça difficile de généraliser
l'allemagne en attend beaucoup la l'on
n'attend pas beaucoup ça dépend quel
allemand de que de quelques de quel bord
politique
l'allemagne a eu récemment aussi la
présidence qu'elle a qu'elle a su
utiliser justement ce qui est indéniable
c'est que ça va être un outil pour
emmanuel macron dans sa compagne salut
on peut dire que le timing est un peu
compliqué parce qu'en effet au bout de
cinq mois y aurait un éventuel choc mais
pour lui c'est ça tombe très bien
finalement de lui parce que pendant
trois mois pendant trois quatre mois il
sera il sera un président de plus en
plus candidat et président de léon
grimpantes de constater pour aller dans
le sens de ce que vous dites elisa que
est mignonne lacroix a intégré dans sa
campagne personnelle la présidence de
l'union saluée d'ailleurs embauché par
certains de ses adversaires alors le
premier gentil je reviens à eau la
chaussée à sa coalition patrick parent
tient jeudi son premier chantier c'est
quoi la gestion de la pandémie c'est
peut-être ça et l'urgence y tout donnant
directement c'est l'urgence c'est tout à
fait d'ailleurs que la merkel avait
présidé la semaine dernière une réunion
avec les présidents de région il va le
faire exactement la même chose
l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est la pandémie
à il l'a dit encore vaccinés vous
vacciner vous et il envisage de rendre
la vaccination obligatoire donc ça c'est
ton se sont vraiment son premier
chantier je crois que c'est très
important le second chantier parce qu'on
a beaucoup parlé de l'europe sur ce sera
important mais c'est le chantier social
une crise du logement il a promis
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
logements notamment des logements
sociaux ça devient de plus en plus cher
de se loger à berlin et donc c'est
vraiment il a une exigence sociale très
importante et ce n'est pas pour rien ce
n'est pas pour rien si il a été élu
chancelier vous savez il était parti de
très bas il est monté très haut parce
que je crois qu'on a sous-estimé l'usure
de pouvoir de la part du parti de merkel
même si elle a toujours une personnalité
très importante très apprécié il y avait
une exigence sociale qu'on a sous-estimé
avec tous ces grèves donc le premier
chantier c'est bien sûr la pandémie le
second chantier c'est le social et
ensuite évidemment tout ce qui est donc
on va dire relations internationales la
souveraineté de l'allemagne comme vous
l'avez dit je crois que ça c'est quelque
chose d'important mais peut-être va-t-il
tâtonner un peu laissé la place à
emmanuel macron qui va exercer
effectivement au 1er janvier la
présidence de l'union européenne mais
rien ne se fera sans l'allemagne
manifestement je crois que ce que
voulait dire est très important et c'est
le seul bémol gère monsieur croit sans
doute que j'apporterai à votre jugement
sur le caractère imperméable de la
france par rapport à certaines
expériences supposer que l'allemagne
rendent au moins de mars c'est ce qui
est prévu le la vaccination obligatoire
strictement obligatoire
ça aura l'impact sur la france et manuel
qui pourrait s'en inspirer pour aller un
peu plus loin
sur le champ national français c'est le
seul bémol que je pensais la
légalisation du cannabis je pensais
plutôt à tous qu'ils avaient ce sera
d'abord
le crois pas je le vois pas ma range sur
sur la vaccination obligatoire si
l'allemagne sur énorme puissance
mondiale est évidemment leader
économique de l'europe rendez la
vaccination obligatoire moi je pense que
l'italie déjà et l'espagne pourraient
emboîter le pas très rapidement et la
france pourrait s'inspirer aussi là il
peut y avoir un effet d'entraînement une
citation en citations d'anne hidalgo
c'était dans un article de nos confrères
du parisien aujourd'hui en france ce
matin
anne hidalgo évidemment la candidate
socialiste à l'élection présidentielle
l'espagne le portugal les pays
scandinaves est désormais l'allemagne
ont un gouvernement social démocratie la
france rejoint ce cercle nous avons une
vraie chance pour de nouvelles avancées
en europe matthieu croissandeau ça fait
rêver une anne hidalgo qui est à
3% dans dans les sondages qu'est ce qui
manque à la gauche française l'art de la
coalition à l'allemande on est sur des
systèmes quand même très différent on
l'a dit c'est un social démocrate mais
il est il va appliquer et mener une
campagne programme de coalition dans
l'esprit français où on rit faut quand
même rappeler aux téléspectateurs que
nous on fonctionne sur le fait
majoritaire ou quand vous avez gagné
vous avez tous vous avez perdu vous
n'avez rien on n'est pas dans une
logique enfin pas parlement où la
proportionnelle permet justement des
accords des coalitions on n'est pas dans
cet esprit d'enfance on a une culture
dans l'antagonisme politique ce à quoi
fait référence à mon avis anne hidalgo
c'est une époque bénie pour les
socialistes qui est l époque où il y
avait le lionel jospin prémunissant
france tony blair prémices en grande
bretagne gerhard schröder après une
estrade allemagne luis rappeuse a pas
trop je pense qu'on voit en espagne et
en italie j'ai oublié mais je pense que
c'était aussi un oui je pense que c'est
le processeur de mario monti voilà
exactement dont le nom va nous revenir
le jeu l'espoir la politique italienne
qui était qui était aussi un homme de
gauche et donc il y avait
[Musique]
à cette époque la voile et les sociaux
démocrates avaient l'impression de
pouvoir mener une vraie politique
européenne et ait mené une des
politiques sinon ressemblante commune ce
qu'il ya c'est qu'à l'époque les
socialistes français passait plutôt pour
les arcs et au delà vendent parce que
tony blair était quand même un
travailliste très libérale gerhard
schröder a fait les réformes que n'a pas
fait
c'est pour ça quand j'entends parfois
virage à gauche sociale-démocrate sais
c'est pas un virage à gauche à 180
degrés du tout du tout c'est vraiment
coalition déjà oui oui déjà il joue
quand même avec des libéraux et puis
c'est quelqu'un qui est vraiment à la
droite de son de son parti social
démocrate en fait il y avait là
l'allemagne avec paris avait trois
candidats centristes les verts sont
centristes armin laschet tu étais aussi
à la droite à la gauche pardon de la cd
ou des conservateurs donc c'était
vraiment trois centristes en fait donc
c'est vraiment pas un grand virage à
gauche même si c'est vrai il ya ces
mesures sociales sur l'augmentation du
smic et la construction de logements
mais c'est pas je ne sais pas on ne peut
pas parler quand même d'un c'est pas ce
n'est pas une politique socialiste je ne
sais pas si on peut répondre à la
question sur un jeu auquel voilà on est
on est on essaye de s'adonner mais si on
ne verrait place et le spd sur
l'échiquier politique français il serait
ou voyez ce que je veux dire dans des
parties un opuscule qui n'existe plus
radicaux de gauche quelque chose comme
ça où il serait donc au sein de la
majorité
voilà la grosse
présidentielle chacun sauf que macha
losc au café alors maintien j'aurai la
question à marc keller
40 fois
toutes mes excuses et oui je crois qu'il
serait peut-être territoire de progrès
qui est le lait le gauche de la majorité
présidentielle nous on travaille
beaucoup avec les socialistes allemands
le principe du parlement européen être
proche de l'allemand nous devons
construire des coalitions dont on
connaît bien nos collègues et les
socialistes allemands en général sont
assez proches de nous qui sommes les
centristes vont pas je fais partie du
groupe riou qui représente la majorité
présidentielle est
effectivement là les progressistes de la
majorité présidentielle française sont
très proches enfin sont identiques au
spd allemand nous avons d'ailleurs c'est
une particularité le les libéraux
allemands dans notre groupe regnauld et
je peux vous dire que nous avons
beaucoup de discussions sur cette ces
règles budgétaires auxquelles sont très
attachés et en parlant dès à présent
puisqu'il ya des règles qui vont
peut-être à nouveau appliqué au niveau
européen qui pourrait être contraignante
pour la france et encore plus pour pour
l'italie ou la grèce et donc voilà tout
ça se fait sous forme de dialogue
d'explication de la réalité des
situations c'est une manière de faire de
la politique qui est assez inconnu en
france oui justement j'aurais revenir à
cet art de la coalition je rappelle les
les résultats en sièges le spd à 206
sièges au bundestag les verts 118 et les
libéraux dont on parlait le fdp 92
sièges et puis on a l'a jeté à un petit
coup d'oeil dans le rétroviseur de ces
négociations de ces tractations pour
aboutir à des coalitions dans le passé
sur les on va dire vingt dernières
années en 2005 il a fallu deux mois en
2009 ça a été plus rapide un mois 3 -
2013-2017 plus compliqué quatre mois et
demi de négociations entre le cd ou ses
souhaits le spd mais et puis donc là
deux mois pour ce feu tricolore c'est le
nom qu'on a donnée christian zacharias
est la poule à cette coalition a retissé
ça est-ce que sa garantie pour autant
une majorité solide ça parce que on a
bien compris à les tractations une
feuille de route très détaillée mais je
vais dire n'importe quoi peut-être que
c'est mon esprit français qui entrent en
jeu mais si les libéraux d'un seul coup
veulent mettre la pression obtenir plus
sur l'orthodoxie est ce qui peut menacer
de partir et éventuellement le faire ça
peut arriver mais c'est rarement arrivé
dans l'histoire de la république
fédérale depuis depuis la loi
fondamentale allemande parce que d'abord
c'est écrit noir sur blanc dans un
coefficient de fer traque d'un montre un
contrat de coalition à la monf homo et
donc ces cas là sont prévues ensuite
comme le disait elisa goudin ça dépend
des lignes rouges fixées par chacun des
partis et en l'occurrence chacun des
trois partis a vu sa propre ligne rouge
respectez écrite noir sur blanc donc les
partis sont satisfaits bon et puis
quelque chose que je voudrais dire qui
est pas tout à fait un rapport est la
question qui m'est posée mais il faut
quand même qu'on le dise une fois ce
gouvernement de la volt a instauré une
parité homme-femme part faites alors
boîtier mois
à l'effectif nous reste une minute
trente du talent et des paroles vous
revient oui pour moi enfin ben oui sur
le papier la parité est parfaite mais on
donne les ministères les moins
importants aux femmes il ya seulement
deux allemands de l'est dans tout le
gouvernement ce qui est très peu et ce
qui confirme toujours cette tendance de
fond que les allemands de l'est ce sont
très peu représentés dans les positions
un doctorat veut dire qu'il avait plu
c'est le d'allemands originaire de la
rda dans le gouvernement précédent alors
en gala merkel et est originaire de la
rda bien sûr mais déjà il y avait à la
tête du gouvernement une femme et une
allemande de l'est
non c'était pas le cas non plus avant
mais on pourrait espérer que ça que ça
s'améliore justement c'est intéressant
que ce soit encore un élément central on
peut le comprendre oui l'histoire des
allemands mais d'abord un petit
correctif parce que il ya une femme qui
ministre affaires étrangères une autre
femme qui est ministre de la défense il
est de la famille et une femme qui sera
ministre l'intérieur
c'est pas quand même des petits postes
peut-être que d'autres parties où il ne
donne pas assez de responsabilités aux
femmes je suis d'accord mais au
gouvernement quand même les femmes ans
de lourdes responsabilités
pourquoi encore cet équilibre est ouest
oui c'est encore une dichotomie on a
bien vu aux dernières élections que les
anciens länder de l'est est considéré
qu'ils étaient victimes de
discrimination il s'est appelé les
relais les oubliés de la croissance
alors que on à jour sont investis donc
effectivement c'est normal regarder
encore effectivement un équilibre à
faire entre l'ouest et l'est ça fait
partie des équilibres au gouvernement
mais sous ces derniers m'ont rappelé au
congrès de l air il ya eu un niçois
contre quelqu'un qui représentait la
région parisienne ça fait partie de la
réalité française aussi oui merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat merci fabienne keller encore
toutes mes excuses mais marc keller m'a
beaucoup fait rêver dans ma jeunesse je
dois l'avouer donc c'était un truc
c'était un très joli compliment merci
merci beaucoup